en el vídeo anterior vimos lo que sucede
cuando tenemos resistencias en serie
ahora vamos a ver qué sucede cuando
tenemos resistencias en paralelo
tomamos un color vibrante magenta y en
esta ocasión voy a dibujar mi circuito
más o menos así donde aquí tengo mi
batería con la terminal positiva la
terminal negativa mi conductor perfecto
pero aquí voy a tener dos resistencias
en paralelo voy a tener una bifurcación
aquí tengo una resistencia
y aquí tengo otro camino con otra
resistencia y se unen en este otro punto
vamos a llamar esta resistencia 1 y esta
resistencia 2 y también indicamos la
poco intuitiva convención de que la
corriente va en este sentido
aunque nosotros sabemos que en realidad
va en sentido contrario quiero seguir
insistiendo en esto porque me parece
importante comprender lo que está
ocurriendo en la realidad de que aquí
tenemos los electrones y son los
electrones los que se mueven por el
circuito de la terminal negativa hacia
la terminal positiva
en la vídeo anterior vimos que al tener
dispositivos o componentes en serie la
corriente en todo el circuito es
constante pero ahora pensemos qué es lo
que está ocurriendo aquí
veámoslo desde el punto de vista de los
electrones que van a fluir con cierta
tasa o cierta velocidad y van a llegar a
esta bifurcación aquí van a tener que
elegir por dónde se van a ir algunos
irán por este camino de arriba otros se
irán por este camino de abajo
si pensamos en ello veremos que el flujo
de electrones en esta rama de arriba más
el flujo de electrones en esta otra rama
de abajo tendrán que igualar al flujo de
electrones en esta parte de nuestro
conductor perfecto y después de regresar
al mismo camino en este lado si lo
pensamos de esta manera y aquí retomamos
la convención de que está aquí va
nuestra corriente y esta corriente
lo llamamos
tenemos a los electrones que se mueven a
cierta velocidad llegarán a la
bifurcación y dependiendo de las
resistencias algunos electrones se irán
por arriba otros para abajo si las
resistencias fueran iguales y seguimos
usando la convención de que digamos que
la falta de electrones va en este
sentido y fluye de igual manera en ambas
ramas siempre y cuando las resistencias
sean iguales la corriente se va a
dividir en la bifurcación ya que se
pasan por aquí pasa por acá y acá se
vuelven a unir por lo que la corriente
en este lado de acá también va a ser la
flecha
no mejor la dibujó bonita la corriente
que pasa en esta parte del circuito
también va a ser y uno
pero veamos cuál es el valor de las
corrientes que se bifurcan vamos a
nombrar a la corriente que pasa por acá
y por acá como idos
y 2 y la corriente que se va por acá
y por acá como ib3
3 podemos podemos imaginar esto como si
fueran tuberías que la corriente llega a
esta bifurcación esta corriente y uno
llega a la bifurcación y es igual a la
corriente que sale de esta bifurcación
que es igual a 2
+ y 3
pueden imaginarse que si 2
es igual a 5 colom sobre segundo
y 3 es igual a 6 colom sobre segundo en
un segundo dado aquí donde se unen ambas
tendremos 5 colores que vienen de esta
rama 6 colores que vienen de esta otra y
entonces tendremos 11 culos
por segundo aquí tendremos 11 blums por
segundo cuando ambas corrientes se
mezcla espero que esto les ayude a
entender que esta corriente de acá es la
combinación de estas dos corrientes
ahora que otras cosas sabemos sabemos
que el voltaje a través de este
conductor ideal es constante vamos a
dibujarlo en otro color
el voltaje a todo lo largo de lo que
estoy dibujando aquí
en este lado d
nuestro conductor perfecto
podemos ver esta parte morada como una
extensión de la terminal positiva y de
manera similar pero ahora voy a elegir
otro color
esta parte de acá que estoy poniendo en
podemos considerarla como una extensión
de la terminal negativa así que la
diferencia de voltaje entre estas dos
terminales la llamamos voltaje b que es
el voltaje entre este punto y este otro
y es el mismo que el voltaje que está en
el extremo de r2 en estos extremos y
entre el extremo de r1
que a su vez es el mismo voltaje que se
encuentra en esos extremos de acá
entonces cuál será la corriente total
del sistema podemos imaginar esta
bifurcación como una caja negra como una
caja negra todo esto
con una sola resistencia combinada por
lo que la corriente total del sistema
será aplicando la ley de ohm voltaje
entre la resistencia total y esto es
igual a la corriente que va a pasar por
r 1 cual va a ser esta corriente 1 que
está pasando por aquí
será el voltaje que pasa por este
resistor dividido entre la resistencia
esto es lo que nos dice la ley de ohm la
escribimos nuevamente acá la ley de ohm
es voltaje igual la resistencia por
corriente o recordando nuestro neumónico
victoria es la reina de inglaterra
despejamos la corriente que es lo que
nos interesa y nos queda que la
corriente es igual al voltaje entre la
resistencia ya hemos dicho que el
voltaje que pasa por aquí es el mismo en
todo el circuito así que nuestro voltaje
entre resistencia total va a ser igual a
este voltaje entre la resistencia 1
más y lo mismo aplica aquí para la
resistencia 2 el voltaje que pasa por r
2 que es el mismo voltaje en todo el
circuito dividido entre el valor de esta
resistencia así que va a ser igual a b /
r 2
todas estas veces son iguales por lo que
podemos eliminar las de aquí o dividir
todo entre voltaje y nos va a quedar
que uno entre la resistencia total es
igual a uno entre resistencia uno más
uno entre resistencia 2
y ustedes pueden decir bueno si tenemos
aquí una tercera resistencia en paralelo
o una tercera rama pues igual aquí
agregaremos un término más 1 entre 3 o
si tuviéramos 4 resistencias en paralelo
56 m agregaríamos tantos términos uno
entre el valor de la resistencia como
ramas con resistencias tengamos acá
ahora veamos si podemos usar esta
información para resolver un problema y
normalmente es más fácil resolver un
problema que explicar todos los
conceptos que están detrás de éste de
hecho la mayoría de los problemas de
circuitos se usan matemáticas muy
básicas vamos a despejar esta pantalla
aquí tengo una batería
más menos de
16 volts
solo para afirmar que aunque es
recomendable dibujar ordenadamente el
circuito yo si quiero lo puedo dibujar
así
más o menos algo aquí hay una
resistencia que hace algo extraño por
acá aquí está el conductor aquí hay otra
resistencia que se une con esta otra acá
y cierro mi circuito
esta cosa extraña que he dibujado y que
jamás verán en ningún libro de texto es
topo lógicamente el mismo circuito que
dibujé anteriormente aunque ahora le voy
a agregar números digamos que esta
resistencia aquí a la izquierda es de
2011 2011 y la resistencia que se
encuentra aquí es de 511
lo que quiero saber es cuál es la
corriente que es circula por todo este
sistema
más o menos dibujamos la corriente por
acá siguiendo nuestra convención
lo primero es encontrar cuál es la
resistencia equivalente y luego usar la
ley de ohm para calcular la corriente
como encontramos la resistencia
equivalente bueno acabamos de mostrar
que 1 entre la resistencia total es
igual a en este caso 1 entre la
resistencia de 2011
+ 1 / esta otra resistencia que es de 5
años
vamos a hacer una suma de fracciones
espero que recuerden cómo hacerla
1 / rt es igual tenemos este término
como un denominador 20
uno más un quinto para que esté en
términos de 20 a vos son 420 amos es que
es 14 tenemos 520 a vos que es lo mismo
que un cuarto 5 por unas 55 por 420 esto
es equivalente por lo tanto nuestra
resistencia total va a ser igual a 4 oms
así que podemos dibujar este circuito
loco como algo así podemos dibujar este
circuito aquí muy bonito con esta
resistencia su batería
que es de 16 volts positivo o negativo
esta resistencia es de 4 a 2
ya que todo esto combinado
sólo 4 oms
si tenemos una diferencia de potencial
aquí de 16 volts la corriente va por acá
dibujamos de nuevo la corriente
siguiendo la convención la corriente va
hacia acá
y nuestra resistencia es de 4 oms puedo
hacer la corriente bueno ya quedamos que
el voltaje es igual a la resistencia por
la corriente
sustituimos valores nuestro voltaje es
de 16 volts esto es igual a la
resistencia de 4 por nuestra corriente
despejamos la corriente nos queda que es
16 entre 4 que a su vez es igual a 44
amperes
ahora hagamos algo interesante
encontremos cuál es el valor de la
corriente que pasa por estas
resistencias